hi I'm Ted ballarat the reason TV by now
you've probably seen slumdog millionaire
the filmed the rags-to-riches tale some
brotherly betrayal and a love story
nothing ah perhaps the only people who
don't love the film where those who
compete against it awards shows the
golden glow those two AR Rahman's
slumdog millionaire Slumdog Millionaire
slum dog named the film follows an
Indian orphan named jamal who grows up
and hits it big on the famous game show
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire ladies and
gentlemen it's an extremely popular show
in India everybody watches it Sheikh
Adhamiya is a senior analyst at Reason
Foundation in the native of India it's a
perfect you know metaphor for the mood
of the country which is that you know
the country's experience is experiencing
this economic boom and people are you
know impatient to get rich quick in some
ways the script tells the story of India
itself a poverty-stricken underdog with
its own rags-to-riches tale or at least
something like it
Slumdog Millionaire is a very
interesting movie because it's you know
it's come at a time when India is taking
off the poverty rate in the last 15
years has been cut in half roughly 300
million people equivalent to the
population of the entire United States
pulled out of poverty this is like real
poverty very high infant mortality rates
of people not knowing where the next
meal is going to come from so how did
conditions improve so quickly for so
many after all india has been stuck in
poverty for a long time even breaking
from british rule in 1947 failed to turn
things around the prevailing thinking
was that the British had been looting
the country and some of their is you
know a grain of truth in that the
problem was that the Indian leaders the
political leaders at that time had this
very Fabian socialist idea and the
problem with that was that it completely
thwarted the Entrepreneurship in the
country dalmia says crushing regulations
stalled progress for example what if the
CEO of an IT company wanted to do
something simple like attend a
conference in the United States what
they came close to six months to a year
to get permission to attend one
conference if he wanted to import
computers into the country he would need
permits a separate permission for that
the stifling bureaucracy was even worse
for India's poor just getting permission
to sell food from a small cart meant
having to get all kinds of licenses so
most of them don't get the licenses that
they want which means that they become
targets for constant official harassment
police harassment for so long poverty
has been the dominant image of India but
then in the 1990s Americans began to see
India as something else as an emerging
high-tech powerhouse something changed
what was it so in the 1990s India
started its economic liberalisation
effort and it did three things it
started cutting taxes they started trade
liberalisation if a competing company
wanted to import a computer it no longer
had to get permission from a
bureaucratic so they liberalized a trade
policy and they deregulated the industry
Jamal Malik you're absolutely right not
even the beloved game show created as
twelth as expanding trade cutting taxes
and deregulating business and all of
those three things made it just easier
for businesses to establish themselves
and provide jobs for millions of other
Indians and essentially cut the poverty
rate in half millionaires were made but
more importantly the reforms boosted the
lot of those at the bottom for one IT
company you know it doesn't just employ
computer professionals it also needs
landscaping services it needs cleaning
services it needs restaurants and so
there have been just tremendous
spillover effects that have essentially
produced a huge of support service
sector and allowed people to get
themselves out of poverty we are going
to have to greatly strengthen our
regulatory apparatus yet here in America
were turning away from market reform a
choc Deshaies some of my free market
principles contrary to popular belief
george w bush had chucked his free
market principles long before the recent
bailouts in 2007 alone he stuffed the
federal government with more than 78,000
pages worth of new regulations it's just
as great conundrum at that eight at that
same time that deregulation and markets
have produced such dramatic results in
India that they are falling into
suspicion in America in the West because
in India after five decades of
government failure we had a small dose
of markets which has produced this
dramatic results so many Indians remain
poor says dalmia because market reforms
didn't go far enough politicians cut red
tape for high tech entrepreneurs but not
for their low tech counterparts so you
know you walk on the streets of India
and it's not uncommon to see you know
scenes of policeman demanding
univ permission slip from a roadside
vendor and when this guy can't produce
it just shooing him away or evicting his
wares or if he has made some money that
you know that day he might bribe the
policeman to get get him off his back
and slumdog millionaire actually did a
very good job of capturing the catching
the plight of those people the
entrepreneurial orphans often joined
gang cysts all mia because it's so hard
to run a legitimate business I'll go for
d London since few will hit it rich on a
game show millions of Indians need some
other way to escape poverty and crime
what India needs to do is continue a
pace with its liberalisation but just
expand it to include the poor people and
the people who are powerless release
them from the shackles of government
corruption and government bureaucracy
expanding India's reforms may not result
in millions of millionaires but it may
produce more thousand heirs more people
with full stomachs living long lives the
reason TV on Ted collar